ja also das ist etwas was mir auch
wirklich sorgen macht sage ich ihnen
ganz ehrlich und so langsam kommt mal
hoch wir haben ich habe das gefühl dass
die ampel im moment noch nicht so
richtig meint lindner betont ist man ja
dann sehen wir es nächstes jetzt macht
noch nicht richtig verstanden hat dass
man ausschließlich den menschen wirklich
keinen gefallen tut wenn man immer neue
schulden macht also wir haben zwei jahre
soll jetzt wirklich corona pandemie
bedingt ausserordentliche ausgaben und
dadurch auch wirklich zweimal ich sage
mal ganz groben über 200 werden schulden
bei rund 300 mehr einen haben also das
war ein mega eigentlich sind zwei ja
noch mehr aber da hat er die 60
milliarden im zweiten nachtragshaushalt
reingeholt ja eigentlich ins nichts mehr
gehören dann sozusagen also dass man auf
solche situation und im nächsten jetzt
muss man einfach sagen da hatte ich
eigentlich gehofft dass man jetzt so ein
bisschen er zumindest nicht mehr so
extrem viele schulden aufbauen wenn ich
sogar mal anfängt ab zu thalia
abzutragen stattdessen haben wir jetzt
einen rekord an schulden jetzt verstehe
ich dass wir haben wieder eine neue
situation die ukraine krise man hat
gesehen muss was machen militär man hat
gesehen was neue kosten im zusammenhang
mit flüchtlingen die pandemie war noch
nicht so schnell weg machen neue
herausforderung bei kurzarbeitergeld und
so weiter aber wenn ich sehe die kosten
laufen jetzt wieder durch ein äußeres
ereignis aus dem ruder dann muss ich
anfangen wirklich mal den mut macht im
dritten jahr haben und sagen prioritäten
setzen wenn das dass das jetzt alles so
wichtig ist auch die entlastung der
bürger wegen der inflation das muss ich
jetzt im moment machen dann muss ich mal
schauen wo kann ich sparen das würde
jeder normale mensch musste es im moment
machen bei der inflation und jeder
normale mensch würde das auch machen und
hier habe ich in diesem haushalt
zumindest bin ja gespannt wie es jetzt
im nächsten macht aber in diesem
haushalt kann ich sagen absolut vermisst
diese tendenz zu sparen ganz im
gegenteil es kommen neue ampel projekte
die sehr kostenintensiv sind zum
beispiel aussetzung der sanktionen bei
hartz 4 empfänger bei verstößen fast
alle halten sich daran die wissen dass
ich sozusagen auch mal
mitwirkungspflichten habe die ganz ganz
wenigen denen wenn man es jetzt recht
machen die sich nicht daran halten und
das kostet wieder beträge und so geht's
ja 1 nachdem an ich kann ihnen sagen ich
habe ja diesen etat ich konnte es nicht
glauben wir haben vorschläge ohne ende
gemacht auch im detail nicht
aufgegriffen worden mache ich hatte das
gefühl jetzt noch so viele schulden wie
möglich jetzt kommt es dann noch an der
schuldenbremse mit der mit dem der
ausrede pandemie noch so viel wie
möglich aufnehmen damit wird dann beim
nächsten mal muss jetzt anfangen zu
sparen aber das ist falsch ich muss
jetzt anfangen zu sparen die leute
merken dass hier lag in den händen der
fdp
saar fdp fcs und nicht mehr verstanden
ist mit der box willen die ja also was
die union auf alle fälle wo sie
angekommen ist nach der bundestagswahl
ist in der verantwortungslosigkeit ich
glaube ich sieht man auch an den
ausraster bedeutungs wird es so weit ist
es noch nicht er war an der
verantwortungslosigkeit wenn ich mir
anschaue in welcher situation wir sind
wir haben mit den kriegen der ukraine
wir haben mit der korona pandemie wo wir
im übrigen ja den haushalt und die
schulden ja er sozusagen geerbt haben
wir wissen ja auch nicht wie viele csu
leider noch in irgendwelchen masken mit
einem stark wie schuldenbremse geworben
absolut aber niemand wusste den 24
februar das ist ein argument und man
muss fairerweise sagen 100 milliarden
die wir jetzt zum beispiel das
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr
brauchen das ist ja eigentlich eine 100
milliarden die ich eigentlich der union
in rechnung stellen muss weil die hat 16
jahre lang nach vermögen es ist nicht
eigentlich eine lüge am bürger
sondervermögen sind sie einfach scheint
ja ich muss gestehen ich würde jetzt da
keine etiketten
bevorteilung markiert sind die faktor
auch schulden ich würde es als
sondervermögen bezeichnen weil das das
offizielle wording sozusagen ist
aber fakt ist ja wir haben 100
milliarden euro die wir investieren
mussten bei 16 jahre lang die bundesliga
gestartet wir haben wir haben ich weiß
gar nicht haben sie das schon mal in an
die chance ausgerechnet wie viele
hundert milliarden in an die chance mit
der opposition geräte also ich kann
ihnen nur sagen wir haben die ganze zeit
da die opposition sieht ja ja aber sie
haben einen halt kapiert dass iris
regieren und dann hier überleben
verantwortlich dafür
macht wenn man regiert das ist er erlebe
ich immer machen doch mit musik immer
die opposition zugestimmt wo ich mir
denke noch nicht ins lokal kommen
da dürfen wir jetzt schon mal
was ich sagen will also wirklich die
verteidigungspolitischen ausgaben es ist
nicht so dass die fdp da so großzügig
war in der zeit wo wir gemeinsam regiert
haben die spd hat auch immer gebremst
also dass die union jetzt ist die mit
aller macht immer das militär ruinieren
wollte also das glaube ich dass können
sie niemandem
wenn wir mehr wollten mussten uns dafür
verteidigen weil sie einfach kann man ja
zugeben die meisten menschen im land
haben auch gedacht das braucht ist wenn
sie in die haben die schiedsrichter ich
würde jetzt mal frau keller fragen als
bürgerin fühlen sie sich gut als die
union das geld verwaltet hat jetzt wo
die fdp ist und wann haben sie sich der
mann gut aufgehoben gefühlt als bürgerin
mit ihrem steuergeld in beim steuergeld
habe ich mich noch nie gut aus ich
glaube dass alle parteien
zumal man ja sehen muss auch die cdu hat
ja die ganzen jahre auch in der großen
koalition mit der spd zusammen regiert
das hat ja durchaus auch einfluss gehabt
ich glaube dass wir einen anderen umgang
mit geld gehabt hätten tatsächlich in
einer schwarz gelben koalition aber
hatten wir ja nicht insofern ist glaube
ich der unterschied nicht so groß ich
würde mich anschließend an der kritik
dass das design nicht mehr erkennbar ist
dass man sparen will in irgendeiner form
und es gebe ja durchaus eine menge eine
menge ansätze was mir viel mehr sorgen
macht ist diese sorglosigkeit mit der
wir in eine riesige inflation rennen wo
die ersparen geringen normaler menschen
einfach weg sind wo ich sage da hat da
sitzt der normale kleine bürger sitzt da
und verliert gerade alles was er hat und
viele bürger haben ja in der korona
paneele ja auch eine ganze menge an
ihren reserven schon aufgebraucht das
heißt es ist viel erspartes ausgegeben
worden weil man die treasury sonst nicht
überlebt hätte und jetzt kommt diese
galoppierende inflation dazu jetzt
kommen die steigenden energiepreise dazu
und unsere regierung macht überhaupt
nichts so und da finde ich schon da da
müsste eigentlich viel mehr kommen und
mit den energiepreisen würde ich anfangs
ja also meine meinung dazu ist ihr leben
immer noch so als sei das ganze leben
ein wunschkonzert denn
schulden haben sie alle gemacht immer
mehr und immer mehr und es gibt genügend
menschen bund der steuerzahler und
andere die aufzeigen wo wir sparen
können es gibt unmengen an aufwendungen
im gesamten ideologischen bereich denken
sie nur an die gender professuren die
eingerichtet werden ich frage mich was
die forschen kein motiv
doch von wegen 250 professorenstellen
und die warnlampe also dann werden vor
allen dingen die
abgeschaffte geschaffen diese regierung
alleine im bereich der staatssekretäre
und anderer in diesem durch staatlichen
bereich zu verwaltende und hoch zu holen
de und kohle zu geben massiv aufgegangen
ist und das ist eine frage der fragen
dann fühle ich mich als steuerzahler die
zeile über 50 prozent steuern insgesamt
fühle ich mich einfach dazu aber als
schwein als besserverdienender nicht
natürlich richtig war hab ich kann auch
im gehalt verraten
sie haben wir haben doch früher geredet
von ganz klar von der freiheit und hören
sie mal zu helfen sie mir mal
[Gelächter]
eine absage nein aber ich bin der
meinung dass ihnen eine eine vielseitige
logisch überfrachteter dinge
sonderbeauftragte für alles mögliche die
unternehmen werden
regelt bis in ihre verantwortung liefen
frauen sie in der führung haben dass sie
mal was ist denn das für ein land wir
bewegen uns doch hier in ein tollhaus
der haben einige auftraten vereinigt sie
gern dass sie haben ja nein es gibt
tausend dingen das ist nicht nur dass
auch diese schlampereien der verwaltung
und die verwaltung allein in berlin wenn
sie sich das bauwesen ansehen es dauert
zehn jahre vom stellen eines antrags auf
eine baugenehmigung bedingung zehn jahre
dann wissen sie da helmut kohl hat
gesagt bei denen diesen leuten werden
wir für möbel und mir heute noch in den
trümmern setzen von 45 sowie sich nur
vorstellen dass aus diesem land geworden
ist eine aufgebrachte monsterbürokratie
die brauchen sie aber weil das wähler
sind es sind schichten die werden
alimentiert weil die parteien gewisse
parteien die auch als wfp brauchen und
das geht auf kosten der
die diffamieren damit frauen die sich so
viel entscheiden für zu hause zu bleiben
und ihre kinder zu erziehen
sie sollten sich schämen